so look this is an incredibly iconic
moment in history the birth of bitcoin
is incredibly iconic because it's the
start of an entirely new era an era
which is really about opportunity
because bitcoin is censorship resistant
money is decentralized and much like
democracy it's actually run by the
people and for the people which means
that it's very much immune from
government corruption and never before
we've seen a monetary network which
really allows the power and the money to
move away from governments and central
banks and actually go back to the people
what's also really fascinating is it's
one of the most inclusive networks out
there right now we live in a society
which is so obsessed with diversity and
inclusivity well bitcoin is that for you
it doesn't matter whether you're an
accredited investor it doesn't matter
whether and what level of education you
have it doesn't matter where in the
world you live what gender you are
whatever it is everyone all you need is
a little bit of wi-fi has access to this
historical money you talked about how it
could displace fiat currency how far
will they go to kill it still well look
bitcoin is a decentralized network that
is the most important thing about it
that's where its value comes from and
that means regardless of what the
american government decides to do it
will continue to prevail and i always
look at china as an example because they
went ahead and they banned bitcoin
mining and so bitcoin miners decided to
relocate to other locations which are
much more bitcoin friendly like
kazakhstan like texas and so what this
shows us is that people actually vote
with their feet so not every country not
every nation is going to be hostile
towards bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies and so innovation will
move innovation will go where it's
valued and i think the american
government therefore really needs to ask
itself you know do we want to be at the
forefront of this inevitable um movement
this inevitable um
innovation or do we want to be left
behind and i'm pretty sure the american
government wants to be at the forefront
of this i just read something from
palopathia saying that this year
altcoins link projects that they're
going to crush visa mastercard he says
short them they're going to get smashed
i mean we're talking about behemoths is
it going to change that quickly or i
mean as the threat from from altcoins
from stable coins from bitcoin is it so
pervasive that right now it's going to
knock some of these financial giants to
their knees it is the flipping is
happening charles that's 100 for sure
but i'm not sure that it's going to
happen in 2022. two main reasons for
this bitcoin aside charmat is very much
looking at web 3d5 and old coins right
now we are still so early the user
experience is unfortunately very clunky
things can be very expensive a lot of
the innovation is happening on the
ethereum network which ha which has
problems when it comes to scalability
we're still waiting for its update which
is supposed to come q1 this year it's
2.0 um the transaction fees can be very
expensive almost unusable and so i don't
really see this in this flipping
happening in 2022 i think we still need
to get there at the end of the day
people still prefer convenience over um
you know the principles that lie um
underneath um like decentralization